Hi? I'm Matt Scrimshire,
I'm a CMS Blue Button Innovator or entrepreneur-in-residence at CMS.
Mark, what's an entrepreneur-in-residence?
And how did you end up in this role?
Interesting you should ask that.
I describe it as being paid by the federal government
to cause trouble inside the federal government.
You know, I think an entrepreneur is someone with a passion
or naivety to think they can change something for the better.
And so, I've always been passionate about Blue Button and so,
I got invited to go in and a tweet
said you should apply for this position and I ended up there.
So, that's how it goes.
Power of the little birdie.
Absolutely.
Mark, can you explain the Blue Button on FHIR project,
and how you came up with the idea.
Blue Button on FHIR.
Blue Button's been around for nearly seven years and,
but it's basically a text file that a beneficiary or
consumer can download from the portal that they use.
The problem is that every Blue Button falls
different which is a real pain for us as developers.
The idea was it didn't really come from me,
but from CMS saying they wanted to upgrade that to become basically a data API.
So basically data is a service,
and I was brought in to actually tackle that project.
The reason it became Blue Button on FHIR is just really a combination of circumstances.
I often describe myself as lazy,
so I didn't want to go and create my own API if there was one out there in the industry.
The advantage of using an industry API is as
the API matures and the tools around it mature, everybody wins.
The idea was really to build Blue Button,
the Blue Button text file that CMS distributes to
beneficiaries as a data API in
structured data format that something the industry is going to be able to recognize.
Mark, can you tell us about the size and scope of the Medicare population and
the claims data set that will be made available through Blue Button on FHIR.
Sure. We're making the Blue Button API at CMS available to
all Medicare beneficiaries and
that's actually a population of somewhere around 38 million,
on medicare.gov itself is around I
think 29 million beneficiaries that actually have accounts.
In terms of the data,
we're releasing a part A,
part B, and part D data.
That's the hospital, the professional, and pharmacy data.
That's in the current Blue Button file
and they currently receive three years worth of data.
If you run that up,
it's somewhere between six and eight billion records
that we're going to be making available.
In your perspective, what are the advantages and disadvantage of
claims data as a source for patient facing apps?
I think the fact that it is just claims data.
The VA and CMS both published Blue Button.
The VA actually has a lot of clinical data in their information set and
that shows that the veterans come back to download that data more frequently.
For us, we really just have the part A,
part B and part D claims data.
It is claims data, but it's also something that
patients will actually recognize because they usually see the bill.
There were a bunch of these,
what we're looking at is because we're building with the FHIR API that the API can be
extended to cover other data sets or other resources within the FHIR specification,
so the Blue Button API could be used for example in a hospital situation or
maybe for the Veterans Administration and be able to release those other types of data,
but using the same basic Handshakes that we are trying to pioneer here at CMS.
After the patient has given authorization?
Exactly.
With blueprint on FHIR,
how do you handle access to the appropriate data?
There's a number of aspects to that question.
Firstly, the Blue Button API will connect a beneficiary to their data.
We'll be matching them.
That's one slight change to
the FHIR specification is that we will be sort of overriding and saying,
"No Paula, you can only get your data."
So, we're limiting what they can release.
It's an important thing to understand some developers
think that by connecting to the Blue Button API,
they can get at those 38 million patients' records.
No, you have to recruit each patient and get them to authorize your access,
so there's that aspect to it.
Then there's the question of well,
how do we choose about trusting applications?
Well, that's a really good question and that is fairly complex because on the one side,
you've got CMS or any other data holder in
this industry takes really seriously the security of their data.
At the other end of the spectrum,
you've got the directive from the Office of Civil Rights and you've got enshrined HIPAA.
The fact that a patient has an absolute right to their data.
Additionally, a lot of people say, well,
what about data being sent off to a hacker in Russia?
Well, actually the fact is,
that a patient can knowingly choose to send their data to a hacker in Russia if they,
if they want to, that they are perfectly at liberty to do that.
The question is we want to try and take steps so that they don't unknowingly do that.
One of the things that we've certainly been pushing with CMS here is
saying every data holder in this industry has the same problem.
Every developer aiming to do work in this industry has
the same problem of having permission to connect to the API.
Well, with Blue Button on FHIR as an API,
you as a developer can connect and get a key,
but you have zero access to any data until a beneficiary gives you access.
What we're trying to stimulate a discussion
around is really the establishment of let's call them
trust communities or endorsers that could endorse third-party applications,
and those applications could bring some sort of token to a data holder like CMS and say,
"Hey, we've been checked out over there."
And in that way what it does is it then starts to
create a scenario where the patient could
see a badge that says this application has been validated by this organization,
or maybe knows somebody who created
an application over the weekend and they want to share it with their family.
Yes they should be able to do that,
but if they do that and we see that they did
that application doesn't have some sort of validation token,
we can at least ask the patient, the consumer,
if they want to do something stupid and share their data with that application.
It's a complex scenario and I think we have to have a range of
solutions that tie together to reduce the risk for the data holder,
make it easier for the developer to integrate
with lots and lots of different data access points,
and the patient to have a clue about what they share and who they're sharing with.
What benefits does CMS hope to achieve by
allowing patients to access their own data through Blue Button on FHIR?
Well, I think we see that really we're entering an era of more retail medicine.
The patient, the consumer is going to take more control over their health.
Well, how do they do that without data?
The Blue Button on FHIR API is really trying to
open up the gates so that consumers can get access
to their data and find partners they
trust to help them look at that data because they do not want the data for its own sake,
they want to do something with it.
They want whether it's to donate it to research,
to put into a personal health record app or some concierge app or
their doctor's EMR because they trust their doctor.
It's going to be their choice.
And we want to simply make the data flow so much like Todd Park said,
it's really about like creating the,
being the knower of` health care,
allowing the data to flow and lets
an ecosystem of applications spring up service particular needs.
And network effects will start to kick in.
Absolutely. When I was
first starting out on this role somebody actually reached out to me and said,
"so, are you going to be building a diabetes app?"
And I said, "No, we're, we're building a pipeline."
And if you were an expert on diabetes,
go and build that app.
What are your hopes and future plans for Blue Button on FHIR?
We're actually building the Blue Button on FHIR API as a two part API.
We're building on the reference platforms that are already emerging in the industry,
and we built a front-end.
It's all open source,
so we would love other institutions and organizations to take our front-end and plug it
into FHIR modules that are coming out of all of the big EMR vendors.
There's that opportunity to create
a more consistent API for a growing ecosystem of applications to connect into.
I think the other side of it is dealing with this issue of trust for applications,
we have to solve this problem for the data holders,
the developers, and the patient.
And so, I'm looking to see that,
to try and stimulate that work,
and to that end there's a few of us that have been working on this opensource front-end.
You can go to GitHub,
look at Transparent Health,
find HHS OAuth server and you'll find our code.
What we're doing is we're evolving that into a not for
profit foundation so that we can have both the commercial and noncommercial entity,
because any organizations looking to seriously append
on an API like this is going to as they say in the industry,
one to throat to choke.
They may want to license some sort of service or support from an organization,
and I think that's a good thing because that would potentially
create longevity around the API,
and see it as it lives on and continues to get developed.
We'd love to see it get adopted not only in this country,
but internationally, which is certainly within
the realms of possibility because FHIR is an international standard.
Thank you so much for your time.
It's a pleasure.